ya lo welcome to this video i'm back
with a new rapid game after quite a
quite a break i'm simply too busy with
my move and and all things so i don't
really find the time at the moment to to
do match for the channel so i'm a 15
minute game on icc and I've got him an
opponent which is with some generated
German quite similar to to myself like
2200 ok plate this night VD 7 line I
think g4 is an interesting answer
intending g5 like he normally replies
with them age six now young not sure how
this is some now continued I could um
fianchetto like Bishop g2 jg to h3 I
could could play some f three set up and
claim that yet somehow created a
weakness hard to tell
yeah f3 I don't know maybe I can play
like this but should be three e5f three
and if it takes Len Queen deform
hmm
okay not sure alrighty so just place the
standard kind of moves here which is
owned preparing here sizzix is preparing
me five so I cannot replay a four so
what be I would be really weird yeah I
should doesn't try to play long castles
quickly and then go for each for Angie
find this is the idea after all it's
certainly risky I mean this is quick
with b5 not sure if this is really a
good plan and then I'm that I'm pursuing
here probably after g4 h6 a move like h3
and Bishop g2 is a wider choice let them
all right let's um let's see what what
we can do here my castle now long as
they probably play b5 instantly now but
what can I do place be five I can play
king be one and an item c2e2 haven't
played 92 yet so the light can go e 2
g-3 it's a possible route
kapla can probably it's all right in
this position you should have any any
big problems maybe you can even try to
play form for long castles some
possibility just Bishop e7 and castles
long I don't think it can have a castle
short i mean this this looks risky with
age 45 he can certainly just display am
a normal move like we should be seven
down clear maybe he's imitated by moves
like Knight takes b5 on ID five which
are always a possibility after King be
one like night be five Queen takes D 297
check it's not working for white but
it's a motif that black needs to be
aware of yeah of course this will also
an idea just them just taking this and
trying to gain time in some way with see
five or something so I feel that this
should be okay for me
if he have a Texas this Bishop thumb I
can eyes I can just take on f6 I guess
it's a the dark squares look look
problematic but mm-hmm on the other hand
I have nice some nice chance to see on
the white squares on the lights class
Bishop c4 Knight to g5 so this must must
be fine for me and we're well where is
he going to cancel i mean cancelled
short after h4 is just impossible i
think this looks rather promising for
white i would say the problem is my dark
squares a week but he's got the bishop
only seven and on his heaven it's not
doing very much it's basically just
protecting the six but that's all and my
next moves are simply not g to e 2 and h
4 and g5 and i'm not sure he needs to
play some defense against this would not
quite sure what it is now looks tricky
oh gee five yeah I thought about that
but I thought 35 would be good for me
pardon me sorry I hope you hmm yeah I
still got some some remnants of this
cult it's not not quite them quite over
yet this is also why I didn't do mmm
videos the last couple of days sometimes
my voice was simply not not good enough
to to to UM to do anything like 20
minutes in a row of commentating alright
so now i can can just win a pawn with
Knight f6 and grabbing on d6 but um I
hard to believe that this should be it
should be the best move I want I want
simply to strengthen this position just
light g3 f5 as an at the end i also have
h 4 ER no h form I mean it's hard to
hard to believe that black woods would
be able to survive this just take him
and open the H file takes with the piece
I can play a form all right let's say
Bishop takes I can play a form
yeah frankly this looks just like a
complete disaster yeah just rook takes
yeah I can just take with the rook is
something better I mean rook takes you
cannot even num take on f3 is made 9700
26 until I can just double on the H farm
like smooth oh they're all this
checkmater 97 a group g6 check Queen h6
made check and mate next move
yeah collapse later yeah I can only move
the king and then queen age six with me
it's made yeah i don't know i think
taking nc5 isn't a good idea really
maybe you can take but c 5s is probably
too much i think black should simply in
this position continue to develop this
should be seven or something can also
think about before and then we should be
seven now but just complete your young
new development no he moved yeah this is
probably this is probably better
probably agrees to to that and now he
backed up alright so this is curious
yeah well I think I'm a pretty a pretty
pretty decent game but I shouldn't
really take on on deform this was rather
short I try to start ok I'll get again
another game so i'll make a rapid
session out of this and play d4 again
and the playing um and someone from the
philippines IAM nicole 23 yeah whatever
and rating is close to two thousand two
hundred and what we get a king's indian
alright so um yeah white choice against
the Kings inion i'll play and play the
same michigan but I've tried all kinds
of her lights against the Kings Indian
the same wish is one of them is also one
of the recommendation son in um industry
for repertoire series that I produced
last year
should be three yeah now it's a curious
moment will black take on d formally I'm
permit me to play at d 45 some
interesting now in fact them blacks move
on already as some slightly suspicious
because um you don't really want to play
this age six move 97 okay yeah well it's
playing them sort of old-fashioned way
there's some this opening so it's not
them completely I'm completely terrible
but it's rather passive
so when my next move will be G form yeah
maybe not now now after g-form he's got
the ideas of playing night f4 probably
and sacrificing a piece and upon I'm
sorry not a piece of course but then I
don't need to do that really i can i can
just get along f5 would be really
questionable ok i'm probably a b5 so one
of his ideas to to stay up trouble
alright so b5 this is really a threat
yeah well not really but yeah this is a
kind of position where black is
basically I'm positionally almost busted
but he will play all kinds of moves to
to stay up trouble this is the first
pawn sacrifice he takes f be sure before
then you will play b5 sacrificing
another porn and white is just two pawns
up but you always need to be be cautious
because of the this Bishop which is
strong on the long diagonal no doubt
about that alright so it should be 22 to
cover to cover here yeah I know before
as mentioned this is just the typical
kind of yeah counter play that black
tries to get mmm when he some yeah he
doesn't have any normal play left he
just needs to sacrifice tough to get
activity but it's not it's not without
its points of course
yeah the question is I mean can I take
it and so it's not not clear if I'm if
I'm able to could take e 5 and b5 but
this is really am really too much I
don't want to want to give away the on
the bishop here now on a form i think i
should play a bishop to d4 and probably
f4 at some point of course i'm returning
a pawn now on c4 button this is
unavoidable yeah G foursome is
double-edged what I plate is just the
kind of shin move that tells black ok I
call your bluff but this is not a
complete Bluff I mean probably it this
is something that the computer world
will defend defender easily against with
white but it's a lot easier norm to play
yeah this is surprising
mmm
sure yeah I think g5 probably provokes
him to play h5 and then I want to go out
form F for light XD form takes takes
bishop d for this is my DM to get rid of
from the strong bishop and get a good
structure as c4 will will stay weak pawn
and any kind of endgame some would be
would be very good for me so my idea was
not see for Bishop takes bc push-up
deform and this should be in quite good
position for white I don't really see
what else you could do
yeah this looks nice okay so let's
Gotham has got this be found way maybe
can try to drum up some some counter
play alright submission fee for can
aptly can or should I take on g7
interesting point or just rookie one hmm
Bishop g7 rookie one Bishop f8 Bishop
retreats I wish to repeat that code
Bishop age six and when okay so i can
just I can take your first clarify this
structure the question is where do I go
now they are probably to e1 still
I always have to squint e4c for grabbing
grabbing the spawn and restoring the
pawn advantage I'm not so much keen on
winning this pawn I mean I can do this
no not not a big deal what I'd like to
do is them yeah get rid of the Queen's
this would be helpful for example on an
end game without any any heavy pieces
Queens offer drugs off would be just
resign double for black I'll get this
pawn and then also have an advantage on
the kingside so would be a very very
easy win okay but this is just just the
theoretical assumption now that he's
played f6 and looks like am King side is
I'm going to be open dealing question is
so how do I react now I can play h4 in
order to retake with the H pawn or I
could play entirely differently taking
taking Queen takes looks a bit looks a
bit strange as Queen our form
immediately as some as a threat but I
could play h3 this is an idea h3 Bishop
back to d7 probably and then we'll come
eat ogone intending to recapture with
the rukon g5 wouldn't be bad probably
okay let's um let's try this get some
play on the G file
only wondering Bishop d7 look to g1 what
if black plays at 50 f by 5 is probably
disaster you know and five is just just
nonsense if I / can like windy 45 okay
yeah how do I continue now f5 look some
aggressive it's probably probably good
yeah f5 gtex at five Queenie to
something like this rg6 when you to sm
place is good it's good though yeah I'm
okay this must be must be correct yeah
just opening it up I'm taking g5 rook g
fibers it's just just curtains so what
now g6 you probably play king g7 and
it's not clear that I have such a great
great continuation so maybe just go into
e to round attacking 85
hmm happy should be eight I can be can
probably play this I bet I can play I
can play h4h form yeah this I I actually
thought g6 should be good but maybe
maybe I'm not evaluating this correctly
it's possible but g6 look strong but it
doesn't open the position maybe this is
the entirely wrong approach why not take
the take on f6 a threatening rook g7
instantly so he needs to retake and then
look g 5a kamal this must be good the
hawk though King Cyrus is open so rook
f6r up g5 very hard to believe that that
there shouldn't be a win
so h5 is hanging if he takes on e4 I can
take what the with the night threatening
Knight f6
yeah it's not them the rukon aah is not
really helping in defense and I'm very
quick now with raga h2g one as a further
reinforcements how to believe that he
could that there is the defense
sometimes you're surprised chest
position is something very resilient
sometimes but looks looks very difficult
to defend if you just protects h5 like
rook h6 I think I'll just go rook g1 and
don't think this should be defensible
now that maybe maybe I'm talked to
mystic let's say let's say place f4 f4
using the f pawn rook takes h5 and
Brooke age success this winning hmm now
on that's probably not an instant win
it's got to Queen five maybe okay yeah
there are thought just ripped umana just
struck g1 attending rock g7
look g7 is not not winning immediately
but so very close to that okay 25 Queen
f forum as soon as a possible possible
idea what about mm-hmm okay this doesn't
help Oh thinking about 23
yeah I can also just to just take it I
mean on age five I think
of course this is some position by
really want to mate what what about
Queen g2 let's just just let's just look
at candidate moves here twin g-tube with
the idea of rock g7 g8 what is he
playing against this move
not much probably the ideas group g7
rook working to edge a truck GA check
King 2h7 and Queen g7 and made next move
not quite sure how to not show how to
defend this why don't i don't see move
really
yeah look slam looks deadly Luke Chisolm
yeah for up to seven can also gather
look on age 6 has known as no square it
cannot move King honking move that stuff
with rook g8 coming and the bishop on d
7s I'm a dead piece I can give this
check on f4 but this is just a spy check
all right that I switched the audio for
a couple of seconds because I had some
really bad calcium okay so I'm yeah this
is basically waiting for for the
resignation I don't see a move ready
would be really shocked if he if you
would find something or sheep don't know
yeah i think this position was some this
position here was fairly are cleared
that some suddenly interesting to play
or black i'm pretty sure though that
this should be you should be good for
white maybe there's something else that
you can do here like am taking now on on
see for how to tablets a very
complicated position yeah well the
game's not over yet he's still thinking
or doing whatever sometimes people on
also simply don't resign for whatever
reason just let the clock run down yeah
but sometimes and you have the strong
feeling that there is something and some
defense and then you simply don't want
to resign i understand that sometimes
they have the same moment the same thing
where I think all right okay i'm bad and
so on but there should be some way to to
defend okay now i can just take on h5
and play Queen g7 made ya made it to
move should be should be ok there's so
many not amazing moments yeah this was
really a really interesting at first I
thought this is just nonsense but what
he did but maybe geforce2 to shop
because this really gives gives black
players is no there's no doubt about
that it's a bit done yeah that's it it's
a bit fishy maybe but it's dangerous no
no doubt about that so on yeah this
looks looks pretty pretty normal
yeah but this this seems better for me I
mean I've got the very good knight on c3
which is very stable cannot be we pushed
away from c3 and it really keeps the
position together this the strong the
Bishop's here get exchanged phantom now
I'm just better with the the night
against the Bishop to Bishop is bit of a
stupid pc and I've got these ideas with
f5 and so on so um this is certainly
certainly good good for me yeah computer
wants to go f5 now immediately probably
stronger no I'm sorry I need to stop him
my voice is failing me hi I'm sorry
really okay thanks for watching I hope
you enjoyed it anyway despite them the
cold symptoms here and yeah have a good
time I'll be back soon hopefully without
them without the coat